this episode is sponsored by indel an
app that creates personalized
soundscapes to help you focus relax and
sleep the first 100 people to click our
description link will get a one week
free trial
[Music]
an Ambiguously long time ago there was
this theory of medicine it was called
the doctrine of signatures and it
persisted for centuries maybe even
Millennia the liverworts we're looking
at right now are a prime example of how
this system conceptualized nature and
Medicine the premise of the doctrine of
signatures was so simple that honestly
we wish it were true the idea was that
if you came across a plant that looked
like a body part that meant it was meant
to treat ailments that targeted said
part in the 17th century an English
physician named Nicholas Culpepper said
this of liverwort it is a singular good
herb for all the diseases of the liver
both to cool and cleanse it
all this pressure put on one tiny plant
simply because it resembled the liver
unfortunately it turns out that medicine
is a little more complicated than the
doctrine of signatures but even though
liverworts can't cure all the diseases
of the liver it's still remarkably
talented capable of cloning itself in a
series of steps that sound like they
came right out of Science Fiction to get
a sense of what liverworts look like in
nature we can actually turn back to
Nicholas Culpepper's writing the common
liverwort groweth close and spread as
much upon the ground in moist and
shadowy places with many sad green
leaves or rather as it were sticking
flat one to another very unevenly cut in
on the edges and crumpled from among
which arise small slender stalks an inch
or too high at most bearing small
star-like flowers at the tops the roots
are very fine and small
the flowery structures and roots that
Culpepper described might make you think
that liverworts are just a normal plant
but liverworts are bryophytes a loosely
associated group of ancient but tiny
plants that don't have the vasculature
we think of when we think of flowering
plants without vascular structures like
a xylem or phloem to transport nutrients
and water around bryophytes can't grow
quite as tall instead liverworts in
their bryophyte compatriots including
mosses tend to grow only a few
centimeters tall even though they're
super low to the ground liverworts make
quite an impression for one they're
bright green filled with chlorophyll to
help them perform photosynthesis
but if you scan along the surface of
some liverwort species you might notice
weird Parts where the cells seem to warp
and turn in strange ways their insides
filled with little discs made out of
plant tissue why we'll get back to that
in a bit
there are two types of liverworts the
less common kind are called leafy
liverworts because of their leafy scales
and flat stems these liverwort look a
lot like moss but their leafy structures
are distinct enough that those who know
what to look for can distinguish the two
the other kind of liverworts are thaloid
liverworts which look more like scaly
structures stretching out across the
ground when Culpepper described
liverworts as having small fine Roots he
was almost correct other words do have
small hairy structures that help it
latch onto surfaces these structures are
called rhizoids unlike Roots they aren't
able to absorb nutrients from their
surroundings
these rhizoids are fascinating to look
at because each one is a single cell
stretched out long and able to hold the
liverwort in place another feature that
distinguishes bryophytes like the
liverwort from vascular plants is that
they don't reproduce with seeds instead
they rely on spores for sexual
reproduction to make this happen
liverworts have two distinct stages of
their life they begin as a gametophyte
with sperm producing structures called
antheridia and egg-bearing structures
called archegonia the antheridia produce
sperm which travels through the water to
find the archegonia on another liver
word so that it can fertilize the eggs
there and when that fertilization
happens a new stage of liverwort emerges
into the world called the sporophyte
it'll continue developing in the
archegonia until it's ready to release
its spores into the world which will
develop into a new gametophyte carrying
on the cycle that process is so sweet
and familiar an egg and a sperm meet and
from there an entity develops into a
life expanding the world of liverworts
just a little bit further but thyloid
liverworts are capable of reproducing by
another means a weirder one all they
need is a cup and some rain remember
that green swirl we saw earlier that
structures on the surface of the liver
word and it's called the Gemma cup its
job is to hold little discs of liverwork
tissue called gym a the Gemma cup and
its Little Gym a form during the
gametophyte stage but they don't do
anything at this point the gym a are
simply dormant
so what does it take to awaken the GMA
brain seriously that's it when rain
pours onto the liverwort it splashes the
gym a out of its cup and carries them
away and as they travel the gym May
emerge from their Slumber so that
eventually when they find a place to
land they become a new plant so maybe
new is the wrong way to put it they're
actually a clone of the old one born
from just a little disc carried in a cup
and pushed out with just a dash of rain
we've seen so many versions of asexual
reproduction in the microcosmos and they
often feel kind of violent or at least
painful if microbes felt the pain of
tearing themselves apart into two
identical clones in comparison the
liverwort's method feels so sweet like
it's just packing its little future
selves for a rainy Journey it's a
version of clones and asexual
reproduction that we probably wouldn't
have conjured up in our wildest science
fiction imaginations it's adorable a
little bit of rain falls in a cup and
out comes a sleepy clone ready to wake
up and spread its wings or I suppose
it's non-vascular body into the world
yeah
foreign
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us and thank you again to
indel for sponsoring this episode endl
is an environment-based app that takes
everything we know about sound and
combines it with Cutting Edge technology
the result is real-time personalized
soundscapes designed to help you relax
focus and sleep sound has a direct
impact on your physical and mental
well-being and with their patented core
technology indole can adapt in real time
to things like your location weather and
heart rate to create simple pleasant
sounds you can use endol to calm your
mind and help you concentrate for longer
periods of time when studying or working
or soothe you into a deep sleep with
soft gentle sounds if you're interested
in trying out indole just be one of the
first 100 people to download it using
the link in the description and you'll
get a free week of audio experiences
those names you're seeing on the screen
right now are some of our patreon
patrons and they're the reason the show
can exist if you'd like to join them in
supporting Journey to the microcosmos
you can go to patreon.com journey to
micro to get weekly wallpapers and
monthly uncut videos
if you'd like to see more from our
master of microscopes James Weiss you
can check out jam and germs on Instagram
and if you'd like to see more from us
there's probably a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
[Music]
foreign